buenas tardes maria belen y cuál es la
situación tectónica de haití cuál es su
comportamiento para que haya ocurrido
otro terremoto como el del 2010 que
provocó miles de muertos
buenas tardes bueno la explicación a que
el terremoto haya sido tan catastrófico
igual que del 2010 podríamos decir que
tiene una componente física y otra
componente más bien social la física es
que prácticamente haití está en un
entorno tectónico complejo está situado
en el límite de placas norteamérica
caribe y en ese contexto hay dos grandes
fallas que atraviesan
toda la isla de la española haití
república dominicana que son la falla
septentrional al norte y la falla de
enriquillo al sur son fallas pues muy
activas y que generan terremotos de
magnitudes en torno a 77 con 2 como ha
sido este pues cada
con cierta frecuencia no pero hay que
decir que el desastre sobre todo el
desastre que hubo en el 2010 esperemos
que ahora no se llegue a tanto porque en
aquel terremoto fueron 300.000 víctimas
mortales no es debido sólo a la magnitud
del terremoto es debido también y
fundamentalmente a la gran
vulnerabilidad de las edificaciones del
país a la vulnerabilidad estructural y
también a la vulnerabilidad social el
país no está preparado para este tipo de
eventos no tiene por ejemplo una
normativa sismorresistente en el 2010
cayó hasta el palacio presidencial
entonces digamos que va a temblar y si
se pueden seguir generando terremotos de
esta magnitud pero habría que reducir
drásticamente la vulnerabilidad de la
edificación para evitar catástrofes como
ésta
haití comparte isla con república
dominicana ya lo decía usted y por qué
unas líneas de falla afectan a más uno
que a otro
no bueno las fallas afectan igual
localmente en república dominicana
también han ocurrido terremotos
importantes y muy severos en esas dos
fallas ahora bien los devotos son
caprichosos ahora se han producido dos
digamos en 11 años en la parte de tiana
pero eso no significa que el siguiente
terremoto por ejemplo que se produzca
más con epicentro en república
dominicana
a lo largo de la historia la actividad
de las fallas si se analiza ha venido
siendo prácticamente igual en la zona de
república dominicana que en la zona de
haití y ya aparece rápidamente cuáles
son las recomendaciones para evitar
máximos daños posibles en un próximo
terremoto
pues desde luego la primera es que se
construya con un diseño sismorresistente
hoy por hoy el diseñar las estructuras
para que resistan los movimientos
esperados en su tiempo de vida útil es
el principio básico del diseño
sismorresistente esa es la medida más
eficaz preventiva hacer también un buen
ordenamiento territorial disponer de
planes de emergencia etcétera pero
básicamente reducir la vulnerabilidad y
en el caso de ti es reducir la
variabilidad cultural y también la
social la social que afecta pues en fin
a la corrupción a que el país no no esté
preparado para no ser resiliente